culture like hippies just fucking love
the Lord of the Rings interesting yeah
there's like the yeast right like signs
on the subways Frodo lives yeah that
explains why Rachel loves us so much yes
oh yeah so this shirt I am very happy to
be wearing drop the ball yes it's so
bizarre
it's just something random Jim heads Jim
has this amazing collection of sure it's
Pete that he like his high school
they're all my mid early nineties yeah
amazing
it's so cool see what you missed out on
he could like original Star Wars shirts
yeah yeah no I like her guy he's you're
a DJ just like I'm gonna pretend like I
had this high school experience right I
was old enough in the 90s to go to high
school mm-hmm
I was yeah it just looks cool now yeah
yeah back in the day were like it's like
yeah yeah cooler when we went to high
school cuz we had the computers yo and
the internet yeah yeah we were fucking
analog man yeah we were in the organic
try stick shift I do not
yeah I'm not jealous about and cry you
know you want you you want scary like
there were some kids in my elementary
school class in the late 80s that like
still were using typewriters ooh
like you know one of the first things I
did like one first papers I wrote I had
used a typewriter typewriter and like
white things out my dad showed me how to
use a started to using the word
processor and then when we printed out
it was one his old self or newzik
we have that we had one of those
whatever dad we've heard something out
or wherever we had to print all of the
old friend Curtis fish of in liked our
bean salad Carmen - she was a dolphin
we were element someone was like stop
some other time when I'm not around
Blasio is do strips just annoying this
one when we got our first laser printer
alright sorry I have no idea which of
these won't do this I should be
interesting I was gonna try it just to
see I don't know it might look too silly
or - just out there but admit you want
to indulge your fabric this is a very
specific right yeah yeah sure yeah
that's how I can wear it go ahead take
that I will just do the bullish yeah
we'll just do bullies oh well I just uh
cuz I first I thought was like a red
thing it's like now I think it's
supposed to be a Callum like a maybe
dead
ah no but now he doesn't look like a kid
a whole world book encyclopedia is it
that was already out peel it but it's
current well just do it sure will do
alive well do lies was that necessary
goggles man uh maybe try it yeah to take
the bullets off we'll see if that works
here I got Wizards dynasty and dizzy
duster do you mean if you better if you
had like a really gruesome like stuff
yeah yeah that actually kind of work
said that that works as a extra a little
bit that's perfect awesome thanks Jim
okay
oh right you can hold that Barbie Oh
demented Barbie go ahead yeah after that
is very dementia it means insanity look
something up yet ago library use this
thing called card catalog ever lacking
oh it was awful
actually had cars yes I remember that I
don't you don't it's it's good your mama
oh we innocent no no it's like we always
talked about air the gory basis to put
really before the Internet it kind of
sucked oh there's some things about the
80s and 90s I'm like amazing and there
are some things I'm like oh thank
fucking yeah thank God we have the
Internet oh yeah the internet like
looking shit up it's all at your
fingertips like back in the day like
okay you had a question about a movie
well I guess we're I am a dragon down
the goddamn film or looking up some book
in the library yo oh it was kind of cool
it was like the hunt the hunt no no it
was awful we need answers we need a
power
all right grams only a year older see I
remember like hearing about a movie and
then be like fuck I gotta find that
movie it's an obscure film and then like
searching for it that was like part of
the fun was like it's a video story but
but just wanting the animal cruelty one
of the gun animal cruelty like oh we
need the laptop we will I was Hamlet
right
no that was cool and it was always cool
like the old videos for us we had like
black curtain yeah I don't know some
doors I'm like what's what the solution
is like you moseyin all right I want me
some porn actually family video still
has that section do they they do and
it's hilarious a family video still
exists that's why I don't understand
like any kind of porn shot being still
open when there is the internet right
that blows me with people go out and buy
a video is like dude you know you get
that for free it's great just like your
old camera
not computer literate alright okay not
computer yeah exactly go like out of
curiosity I'm like how is this still
open like it's four years for your pair
tailoring your residue I did go into
like one of those video shops one time
and I'm like how is this still open I
would go down there it's like sparse and
just vacant and I just see like tulle
games so you're just kind of browsing
and like super gray
now we're gonna go Randy's on the floor
he's gonna be looking at the laptop
looking at your incredibly violent dog
videos yes
raps you owe me had a referee well
you'll you'll throw the flag blow the
whistle
I'd say what's the line you would
probably start out by saying during the
review and then whatever the line is and
then there's all these hand motion yeah
Mason I just make sebab like flag too
easy a joke penalty has to say something
nice about the movie yeah okay I'd say
flag dirt I would go during the review
too easy of a joke
on the MC Klein is red you look at Stein
having played a bitch I had these
goblins okay here we go
I've got swag during the review uh too
easy a joke replay last line critic has
to say something nice about the movie
okay yeah
replay last replay less line um alright
so I'm gonna say I know casting uh yeah
I do casting heavy now ball and play a
bitch they throw it in that'd be like oh
come on come on hey agent yeah that
would be so many roughly today hey Glenn
was it ideal casting having Alec Baldwin
play bitch that's not how they do it
this let me play the part I mean you can
love it yeah what's in there Oh probably
doesn't need to be weighted that much
that's pretty hard and that's how it
would be thrown they throw it straight
up and then they can do it depends where
it depends where they're at I feel a lot
of the Delta you let it see it thrown
straight up or they'll kind of throw it
into a church right I mean kind of like
that yeah that look like so you can kind
of like it maybe a little bit like what
I was doing
yeah now look at that look good for Rick
kill this tape okay ready when the set I
feel casting heavy Alec Baldwin play a
bitch oh come on
come on yeah I look forget Oh Helen
Reddy help I do casting and I like that
I think
dancing hey hey Wow I feel casting heavy
Alec Baldwin play a bitch oh come on
good man that way could this audit that
flag cost us at least a thousand flag
it's about a thousand bucks IRS I swear
no idea that high-tech technology that
went into manufacturing that their flag
we 3d printed it it's true we did 3d
print a flag Oh Malcolm go home yet you
stand I hate doing stuff on the spot
oh all right well then give it a minute
I'm trying to think about it other than
your news it's yeah I'm gonna end up
that last interview did we just came off
like a bitter like like complete shit
bitter one right what was he saying it
was like about us anyway assault device
layered like I took my kids and a white
slavery that's what this Von Teese and
the Java shit yes special that's very
good Mike I am a tool oh now do my
cocaine oh oh we talked about we can see
the ones like them and Robert aim is
multiple days yet Oh such an awesome
still showers of colors we got shadows a
bad car but they must fun eh completion
will be covered the lightest read comic
book I tied with deuce it for a panel
discussion with massive white when we
share the same bed
interview but the bus a bed to say for
yourself no thing you never bring throw
it and we catch me visible Kino akin to
him this thing don't look like a thing
on TV looks like a sausage ad
yeah
for the sausage looks like this dinging
yeah finish the whole thing like that
and the Perry baby saw curtains please
is it yeah there's anybody has some
specialized material yeah like the Ghost
Rider will rain once I was like oh yeah
like it really needy children that was
always really cool and I remember what
that next film was first released I was
a big thing now like before or five
covers that was together and stuff and
it's like all this stuff I'm like oh
yeah this is the back breaking yes wow
the first issue of guardians of the
galaxy goes yeah it is all those things
that it's just like shit I'd really want
to realize sweet the adventures of Bart
man I actually have it I'm sorry Bobby
those offers I'm likely huffing
Gibraltar
look at it no it's in way too good
condition to be anything of ours oh
that's that's other editorial on do I
want to do one on the mask comics
because if you compare to the fucking
amazing they work yeah
have you ever read the mask I've heard
ok ok you know the Jim Carrey puts it up
the cartoon characters I just imagine
the exhale you'll look like a fuckin
long star path it's just love it like
okay the movies are a time revenge
fantasy but just imagine like on top of
the jokes he slaughters them to death
like it's super bloody and super sore
just imagine if the mask was done like
Deadpool
yeah but like even work I mean it's like
shot up in machine-gunning is grandpa
rustling it's like I mean it's cool and
Walter one of the greatest villains yeah
dogs ever fucking Walter did you read
the mask no never in the missing it's
fucked up I'll tell let him see it there
he's got a Walter that's credible proper
bomb so this is
the comic book show yeah you know we're
doing behind scenes - yeah the comic
book show awesome comics as of right now
we're talking about other name but I
think we're gonna go with awesome comics
okay yeah you like this since yeah
Tizen but it works it works awesome copy
yeah we shooting the promo so I was
gonna add this hopefully have it up our
next week verbs are later this week
maybe depends yeah it's and so you guys
are in oh really yeah
oh I'm excited I'm super excited oh okay
yeah wow you got the whole the whole TV
format going yeah it's all Senate oh
okay
which is very specific yeah anytime
there's a magazine that's what we always
try okay yeah in a bowl oh please
another quick please make sure they see
it it's it's a cumulative legacy yeah I
actually might work as I had Malcolm
head you say you know Shawn Mendes is
Shawn Mendes I guess one of those he's
like the new teeny bopper kid oh I seen
some stitches I think oh yeah yeah I
never told my sister I was like who
who's like the current like teeny teeny
bopper yeah right so yeah so that's
gonna be like yeah so you can't like do
they shove out of the file right there
exactly so it's awesome so you like you
got my magazine now like OK Magazine
yeah
like Oh Shawn we need the cookies um I
was gonna have like sort of like a
walkthrough thing so I end up here
that's where you come out from behind
the dog so just feel I leave behind the
choice yeah actually yeah and so yeah
you you graduated as a television major
right
I will independent film digital energy
so I were going to work though I did a
lot of television work yeah yeah I have
a good mix of that nice background so
awesome so yeah it's gonna be fun I'm
looking forward
guess what our just matadv by yeah yeah
I would just start like I don't I do all
my job I mean I always can try to cut to
some some like the test page oh it would
be cool if you do a one shot if I could
remember all these lines yeah Merida
yeah yeah but we could we could get a
shower okay I was thinking on the way
here like before me if we started you
know this new guy thing isn't exactly
the most glamorous gig in the world but
they said that they would give me on
show if I did what they say they could I
think God Doug isn't here though then he
shows up I legit yeah guys thank God
Doug isn't here though oh my god the guy
has me watches old underwear who keeps
twenty-five-year-old
you walk adventure briefs he's sick if
you ask me of course he'd probably kill
me if he knew that I told you that you
can't like clear your throat or
something to stir
I need your tragedy Oh Rob is leaving
everyone and we're pretty much where
Malcolm is that's where the NC is okay
ready and action
haha right Justin Wright action door
action so I'm sorry oh yes your heart
don't you try my wife before usual pussy
oh yeah if you want to be right action
my wife recorded you for clickbait
everybody's gonna click on a negative
review of Deadpool hmm
tell the comments that they're so angry
they're actually forming a stream of
consciousness that movie was a
disappointment I think it's okay I I
thought was gonna be funnier yeah I did
you it was just nothing like landed very
well which movie uh enchanted
oh that like you know that's cute oh you
know but turns on it and that would be
amazing is that I just really did not
expect it it's the same thing as cats
and dogs like I thought it would
legitimately be funny and it was like oh
looks like crap and I sound like hey
like I really thought be crap yeah yeah
it's cute yeah yeah again assess me what
it James
yeah Marston yeah it just call Cyclops
oh yeah I like they gave oh yeah that's
right you answer it and that's the last
thing she would ever do for me
okay so this is pretty much the scene
where the two kids are here and the
father and stuff and we do that down you
you see okay kids time to watch cats and
dogs and yessir hold up the DVD like
bandits are act like you're putting it
in and you saying you're watching the
movie you know II didn't say that you're
standing here be watching out the TV and
just it's funny because it's funny
because it has cartoon sound effects and
then maybe if I do want to do that
follow-up job the what's your dinner
honey
uh yeah just you guys like hot dog
I like Yan labs gonna this is lies lies
lies
uncle yo it was you all along lies uncle
uncle uncle lies deceit aunt disease
come on that's what we got it they were
not care they were just in the city lies
Wow
like that that's perfect yeah I feel
like that's great uncle the seat it's
like who are these people
okay yeah yeah so where the kids are
about and actually all right kids time
to watch cats and dogs it's funny
because it has cartoon sound effects
that reminds me what's for dinner
you guys like hot dogs right is so good
see the secret is money just yeah yeah
and really just packed about oh it's
like hunter is like not dressed ops is
just nothing without the little
cigarette super winds up on the it's
funny because Pargo sorry I talk like
you know you're playing the TV yeah
that's good it's funny because it's kind
of hard
and this why I say doing smile just you
just play here you're still saying it's
good butchers yeah it's still hungover
okay I'll think she's ever sober yeah
and the character too but where's my
drink
okay hey I just realized we do have a
it's like right behind I think it was
like it is there maybe we could just
like turn around it like I don't know
like I just it just be aware that it
just maybe just like right here or
something as you're talking you know the
under your arms is it just wish I could
pull out my bra guys like hot dogs right
just like hot dogs right all right kids
time to watch cats and dogs it's funny
because it has cartoon sound effects
there much Manny what's for dinner
you guys like hot dogs right oh great oh
my goodness
every of her dresses I should be like it
work up like I should be like um like I
used to smoke so good now I don't I
should say like I'm recovering with a
palette I used to smoke I'm worried
alcoholic of then takes a drink of yeah
we recovering alcoholic what you're
drinking exactly I'm recovering my uncle
just one day I saw just one day I saw
John Cleese - I just didn't go so good
like it's so good - more space was so
adorable how fascinated you were I was
here I'll teach the kids watching how I
mean this is that that's just you boom
you just sort of spin up in the air and
going down that side or the other thing
what it is is that you throw it towards
your muscle and then you bump it like
that and you usually what people do is
they go like that yo hun boom you know
or like that but to make it look more
fun you go bunk and bring your hand
around like that so pretty much are you
do you throwing it like this lemmas boom
and then boom like that right and then
there were towards yourself yeah yeah go
here's we do it throw you up like that
that's right do it that's not what you
do you literally when you drive you have
to let go here so that then when you
bring it up and going that yeah yeah
it's mechanics yeah that's got a baby
aren't you so you have to actually go by
Jess yeah okay I may be Stephanie's no
you're very talented
I just likes I just saw Jenna cleats
doing one day and I was just like that
looks easy it's easy for me
Wow but I can't juggle at home like I
what I see even there like right just
start with one ball I'm like did you
used to sit there and practice it for
like two hours can you juggle yeah yeah
yeah now I want to see you too just like
you're just juggling you're doing the
Harmony
hey by the end of it I think it's the
only ball we have yeah you scarf trouble
huh flames set the scars on fire first
story California four dollars that's all
snot I was like this is nose amazing
singers you know I love it so we have to
riff stores and we have like these
really niche novice stores it's have
clothes like that like I was at this
place called Hollywood mirrors oh yeah
you've been there oh yeah yeah but it's
like so expect crazy yeah they got it
from a thrift store and then they're
reselling over like ten times the amount
yeah like 30 21 go there it's it's kind
of a good mystery journey yeah yeah yeah
trend on it if anything doesn't make
sense like it's either Trumper hipsters
very active but they sound like
Christmas sweaters for like $30 each is
like yeah dollars you trash yeah now go
ahead I'll be a camera what you guys
doing back here
China China China China
but yeah something nostalgia